as important as it is to cross
disciplines to transgress boundaries
whether it's science and our different
boundaries within science it is very
tough to do in practice it is very tough
to interact with someone who speaks a
different language who uses different
acronyms who attacks problems from
different perspectives so I think we
have to do everything possible to not
only encourage this to give out more
grants that fund it funding is of course
a huge huge problem for
interdisciplinary research but also I
think begin to make a serious rigorous
case these kinds of interactions I think
too often is easy to write off
interdisciplinary collaborations as kind
of feel-good exercises I think the
research and literature make clear that
that's often a really really if not the
most productive way of coming together
way of collaborating and in the sense we
see the most when we're on the outside
of a field looking in well my favorite
examples of this is the website
InnoCentive comm which is it's a
crowdsourcing website used by various
fortune 100 companies so Eli Lilly
helped develop it but you know Pfizer
uses it Procter & Gamble uses it General
Electric Kraft Foods companies with huge
huge R&D budgets and the billions of
dollars what they do is they post their
hardest scientific problems on this
website the problems their own
scientists can't solve and they attach
reward to it so if you can solve a
problem for GE a chemistry problem say
maybe you'll get a million dollars maybe
it'll be fifty thousand dollars who
knows but but you know that's the
incentive part of incentive now the
first surprising thing about a no
center.com is that it works about
anywhere between thirty to fifty percent
of these problems are solved within six
months some are solved within days of
being posted online so I mean this is
kind of surprising I think because here
the problems that these huge companies
can't solve and yet some stranger
sitting on his couch in his pajamas
while eating Froot Loops is solving them
making it look easy now what's most
interesting but InnoCentive is how these
problems get solved and this is work by
crema Connie at Harvard Business School
he is shown that let's say GE post a
chemistry problem online that prom is
almost never solved by another chemist
instead it's solved by a molecular
biologist bye-bye
physicist by someone who knows enough to
understand the terms of the question but
doesn't know so much that they run into
the exact same stumbling blocks as that
chemist back at GE so this is you know a
real testament to the virtues of outside
our thinking and outside our creativity
and I think we have to realize that this
is this is a real thing that we have to
incorporate in you know and you know in
everyday work you know in the everyday
world because I think we come with this
tacit assumption then if you're
struggling with a really hard problem
you got to give to the guy who knows the
most to those expert insiders but
sometimes when it comes to creativity
innovation sometimes knowledge is a
blind spot sometimes we can know too
much sometimes we have our best thoughts
when we're working with someone in a
different field tackling a problem just
beyond our area of expertise so I think
that's that's a very practical case for
interdisciplinary collaboration